[Musique]
c'est plutôt vrai c'est faux cette année
ça a été vrai dans le passé alors c'est
pas totalement vrai sur cette édition
faut avouer que les billets sonont
souvent assez chers pour la population
locale que les stad sonne souvent creux
pendant les premiers tours mais cette
année quand même en Côte d'Ivoire mine
de rien on a vu de belles affluences à
peu près dans tous les stades malgré
quelques problèmes de billetterie mais
les organisateurs ont bien repris en
main la billetterie et là je trouve que
c'est de plus en plus plein et c'est
pour ça que cette année c'est
exceptionnel c'est qu'on a vraiment une
compétition avec un maximum de stad
remplis ou en tout cas très bien
rempl ah ça c'est le grand cliché
journalistique qu'on entend tous les ans
et je suis désolé de dire mais c'est
plutôt vrai il n'y a plus de petites
équipes à la canne on est quand même
surpris parce que les équipes qu'on
considéré comme petites et namibi Cap
Vert Mauritanie évidemment on
s'attendait pas à les voir à ce
niveau-là le niveau moyen des dites
petites équipes augmente énormément
elles sont de mieux en mieux organisées
l'écart est de plus en plus faible mais
c'est aussi peut-être parce que les
dites grosses équipes sont un peu en
crise on peut évidemment citer en
premier lieu le Ghana et l'Algérie le
problème c'est que les grandes équipes
se sont affaiblies et surtout les
grandes équipes ont moins de grands
joueurs on se souvient des années 2000
avec Jeurs comme Samuel eto on se
souvient de Yaya Touré on se souvient de
seduketa pour le Mali eux ils étaient
dans les top clubs européens et c'est
beaucoup moins le cas aujourd'hui bref
il y a plus de petite équipe à la canne
c'est pas plus mal pour le
[Musique]
spectacle oui c'est folklorique si on a
un état d'esprit européen oui c'est
toujours un peu folklorique mais c'est
le propre des grands événements quand on
compare avec des compétitions comme la
Coupe du monde de rugby avec l'euro par
exemple oui oui ça apparaît un peu plus
olé olé il y a toujours des trucs qui
vont pas problème de son en conférence
de presse mais c'est des choses qu'on
voit aussi à la Coupe du monde en Ligue
des Champions faut se rappeler que par
exemple le la finale de Ligue des
Champions organisé en France il y a eu
d'énormes problèmes de flux de
spectateurs après si on veut voir
l'ouvert à moitié PL on peut dire qu'il
y a quand même un peu d'amélioration les
standards d'exigence ont été relevés de
plus en plus d'autant maintenant qu'il y
a 24 équipes donc il faut un effort
conséquent sur les infr structure je
trouve que c'est plutôt bien organisé
cette
[Musique]
fois-ci alors ça ça a souvent été vrai
et le pire exemple ce fut le l'arbitrage
de la rencontre entre la Guinée
équatoriale et la Tunisie en 2015 où là
c'était un arbitrage maison caractérisé
je pense notamment au Tunisie Malie l'an
dernierfin il y a 2 ans au Cameroun où
le l'arbitre avait eu un coup de chaud
et avait sifflé 10 minutes avant le vrai
coup de siffl final mais cette année on
est gâté je pense que l'avar a corrigé
pas mal d'injustice qui aurait pu avoir
lieu ça a quand même modifié
radicalement le le rapport de force donc
aujourd'hui rien à dire l'avar c'est
vraiment quelque chose de de top
topissime pour le football
[Musique]
africain ça c'est un vrai cliché non non
c'est pas t le pays haute loin de là là
il suffit de regarder l'histoire mais
rappelez-vous Cameroun c'est pas le
Cameroun l'Égypte c'est pas l'Égypte
depuis 2006 depuis la Coupe d'Afrique en
Égypte plus jamais le Pay n'a remporté
la compétition donc ce n'est plus
vrai qu'estce que je t'avais
[Musique]
dit